in economics and public choice theory
rent-seeking is a behavior that is aimed
to increase one's existing wealth
without creating new wealth for others
in other words it describes the tendency
of some people to seek profits without
doing any real work
a classic example of rent seeking is the
story of a lord
the lord inherited a lot of land and
wealth and never worked a day in his
life however as the lord knows of
another man who has even more than him
being wealthy isn't enough he needs more
and he has an idea
the lord sets up a chain across the
river that flows through his land and
hires a collector to charge fishermen a
fee if they want to pass through
there is nothing productive about the
chain
the lord has made no improvements to the
river and is not adding value to society
in any way directly or indirectly except
for himself
all he is doing is finding a way to make
money from something that used to be
free
to society there are three costs to this
first the direct costs the fisherman who
now has to pay a fee needs to sell the
fish at a higher price to make a living
on the market fish become more expensive
for everybody
then the opportunity costs the lord
invests his money and resources into
equipment that adds no value to society
instead of investing into something
meaningful such as fixing up the broken
school building
lastly the moral costs the fisherman
feels that paying for something that
used to be free is unfair and following
the lord's example is more likely to
engage in rent seeking himself what if
he were to eliminate all his competitors
and then increase prices
the fisherman turns to his friend a
smooth talker who cares for the
environment to help him convince the
lord of an idea
if a fence were to be running down the
banks it would protect the river from
overfishing because access would be
limited when rent seekers and moral
advocates lobby in teams economists
speak of bootleggers and baptists the
lord agrees and soon after the river is
being protected
once the fence is built only a few
fishermen are able to access the river
that means our fisherman not only has
more fish than ever before but he can
also keep selling them at very high
prices
to keep it that way the fisherman and
his lobbyists soon form the fishery
department under the royal patronage of
the lord
from this day on only those who pay a
license fee are allowed to fish in the
river the lord gets a nice cut for his
growing empire
on the market the fish have become so
expensive that the commoners begin to
complain
unfortunately there is little they can
do
[Music]
without ever taking notable risks the
landlord the lobbyists and the fishermen
get richer every day or as economists
would say without having skin in the
game they create a lot of wealth for
themselves but no wealth for society
in theory rent-seeking behavior reduces
economic efficiency through the
misallocation of resources it also
hinders the creation of wealth reduces
government revenue increases income
inequality and potentially leads to
national decline
the term itself was coined by british
economist david ricardo who had built
his ideas on the thoughts of the
scottish economist adam smith the
original meaning of rent does not refer
specifically to payment on a lease but
to gaining control of land or other
natural resources
in 1776 adam smith wrote as soon as the
land of any country has all become
private property the landlords reap
where they never sowed and demand a rent
the wood of the forest the grass of the
field and all the natural fruits of the
earth which when the land was in common
cost the laborer only the trouble of
gathering them come to have an
additional price fixed upon them he must
then pay for our license and must give
up to the landlord a portion of what his
labor either collects or produces this
portion constitutes the rent of land
how about you
where do you see rent seekers are they
in your government and in the
corporations or do you see them in the
streets in the form of gangsters or
corrupt police maybe you even have your
own personal story where you seek to
profit without adding any value
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts